[Music]
it's Darien in La Vie Danny and will he
betray her it surtsey really pregnant in
this video I'm going to deliver you the
answers on some of the most asked
questions in the game trans community
the best part is it's not just my take
on all these important questions which
sometimes may but also may not be
important but it's all coming from an
official gaming transcript itself the
West's Guild of America vast library
houses doesn't subscribe from Game of
Thrones
provided by HBO these scripts have been
on display for the public to see for
years but it's only now they're
garnering attention from a social media
post promoting the library's game of
trans content after years of being
hidden in plain sight somebody has
finally caught on and has gone through
all the donated scripts to see what we
could amaze that may give us an idea
about the upcoming eighth and final
season of course these are the scripts
from the previous seasons but still it
doesn't stir quite a bit of questions we
have going into season 8 and the
answerer stole that could potentially
spoil the final season the official game
of Thrones script sheds light on several
contested details from the show's
seventh season including Tyrion's real
feelings for Danny game internals has
confirmed what many fans had expected by
the end of last season that Tyrion
Lannister is in love with Dana Targaryen
for season 6 episode 10 the winds of
winter the script reads at one point
then he's staring into the distance so
Tyrion is able to watch her from up
close
goddamn she's beautiful he watches her
for a bit too long and turns away lost
in her own thoughts she doesn't notice
that his flustered season 7 episode for
the spoils of war makes this even more
obvious during the scene where Tyrion
watches Jaime put himself in mortal
danger by charging at Danny and her
dragon drogon the script says the
brother he loves races towards his
probable death at the hands of the Queen
Tyrion also loves Peter Dinklage who
plays Tyrion hinted the dis character's
true feelings for Danny earlier this
year the question was why the tear in
her a rather dark and troubled
expression upon realizing that Jon Snow
and Danny are consummating their
relationship and what was Tyrion
thinking to himself at that very moment
keep it down over there I'm trying to
get some sleep Dinka jokes but then he
gets serious and delivers a rather
thoughtful and detailed answer no it's
complicated Dinklage says a lot of the
time baturin it's professional and
personal obviously his feelings for
Danny he loves her or thinks he does
she's all inspiring
he's questioning that because he doesn't
have a good track record for falling in
love there's jealousy wrapped up in
there and he loves Jon Snow 232 people
he is the most in common with in
we're both outsiders in their own
families who have refused to follow the
path their family has taken and
hopefully for the better he's wondering
how smart if a move John and Danny
getting romantically involved is because
passion in politics don't mix well he
knows the two of them getting together
could be very dangerous
so basically it's a mix of feelings
Darrin's jealous because he loves Danny
but also worried for her because he
thinks this relationship might not end
well with that finally established Game
of Thrones fans have something more
concrete to hold onto when formulating
their theories for the upcoming season
it's not a coincidence that people
behind the series opted to an Tyrion
Season seven story with him in the
shadows knowing fully well that John and
Danny were consummating their
relationship his love for Danny knowing
that her affection now lies with someone
else could very well push the royalty
elsewhere or it already did after all we
still don't know what he inserts he
fully talked about in her chambers when
they reached out to her regarding the
threat brought about by the white
walkers additionally it's also hinted
that Danny might not be who Tyrion wants
to see on the Iron Throne
it's script revealing that he sees Danny
the same as his sees her father the Mad
King love is not the only motion Tyrion
feels for Danny he also fears her and
fears for what her role would bring upon
the people of the Seven Kingdoms
especially as Danny Burns Randall and
deacon Tarly alive inside here installs
the striplings Danny took her made
father King Aerys Targaryen
tyrians thoughts are their last best
hope is also her father's daughter I
don't know it's confirmed Cersei
Lannister pregnancy Cersei Lannister
really pregnant it's one of the
questions Game of Thrones fans have had
going into season eight there's been a
lot of speculation that Cersei who has
been known to stretch the truth now and
again was faking her season 7 pregnancy
completely in order to manipulate both
Jamie and Tyrion however the show script
offers no evidence of this quite to the
contrary when Cersei first tells Jaime
about her pregnancy the script reads she
knows it's true her happiness is
contagious they get another chance at
family this time with no one standing in
their way a man Tyrion later do sister
sacred the script makes it clear that
Cersei is caught off guard him finding
out was apparently not part of some
master plot Tyrion sees what he sees and
knows what it means he can hardly
believe it but knows it to be true
she stays silent for too long long
enough to tell him that he's right and
once she knows he knows she can think of
nothing else to say
incidentally that season 7 finale scene
cuts out right there
now hint as to what kind of bargain
Tyrion and Cersei is strong behind
closed doors so it's Tyrion betraying
Dany that question is obviously not
answered in the script says it's not
season eight scripts if you have by the
scripts of the previous seasons but I
did provide all the clues and set the
ground for such a twist and betrayal to
take place let's recap what we got so
far
Tyrion loves Danny but also sees her as
her father's daughter fearing for what
rule could bring upon the Seven Kingdoms
Tyrion is jealous of Jon Snow
Cersei no sirs is pregnant and V on the
other hand also know her pregnancy is
real Tyrion and Cersei had conversation
behind closed door and we don't know
what kind of bargain it is truck so it's
Tyrion really betraying Danny there's
actually one reliable leak that was
shared a few months ago and everything
seemed to support it this lake of course
may or may not be true but all the clues
those seemingly lead to such an outcome
the following contains potential
spoilers for the final season of Game of
Thrones so if you don't want anything to
be potentially spoiled for you it's time
for you to close this video ok the leak
I'm talking about is the one which
claims that hearing the trader and he
will face a trial at the dragon paid for
upon he'll be sentenced to death and
this time he will not get away with it
the league says Tyrion is taking a walk
with Jon and I was thinking laning this
is before trial and it's the aftermath
of destruction of the city their
lifeless bodies everywhere a lot of
innocent people the camera pans to
Tyrion showing him horrified thinking to
himself what have I done we have known
for a very long time that King's Landing
will be burned to ground at some point
of the final season as all the leaked
photos confirmed it but we never knew
who was responsible for the burning and
now not only does this leak explicitly
says it's Tyrion but it also says that
he did not even do it to kill the nine
king's army as there were no whites or
white walkers inside the city walls when
this burning took place turns main and
the only objective was to kill the
people of King's Landing all 1 million
of them tyrians objective was to avoid
the city population from turning into
whites in other words theorem probably
thought the night king would end up
taking the capital so he decided to burn
it and it's 1 million people in order to
prevent night came from creating a huge
army that would probably be hard to
defeat at that point it's Brandon his
three eyed Raven skills that's going to
be an end for Tyrion brain is the one
who tells of Tyrians betrayal twitter's
Tyrion will then be imprisoned and put
under a trial Tyrion will say they
deserve it
implying that the people of King's
Landing deserve to die the most
traumatic moment of the trial will be
Tyrion falling on his knees in the
middle of the speech dragged down by his
actions
it says that he will not be able to ask
for a trial by combat although this will
probably be the best possible way for
the cool game ball to take place with
mountain being Tyrion champion as his
side of it Circe it's a known hovel
Tyrion be executed because unlike the
trial his death was not filmed in
Seville but in stereo so according to
the leak Tyrion will definitely be
executed for his crimes
long story short Tyrion is a trader he's
being judged for 18 games finale he's
betrayed Danny and his side of his
family he also burned King's Landing to
the ground along with its population if
this is coming as a huge surprise to you
should check out my theory on is a
trader Theory video in which I provided
you all the evidence and clues of him
preventing House Lannister from falling
during the entire past season
additionally all his war plans were made
with sole purpose of weakening Danny's
armies and strengthening House Lannister
position they've been taken from me
while I've been sitting here on this
island who won't be able to eat because
Cersei has taken all the food from the
reach clan it's still the right plan
your strategy has lost a stone the Iron
Islands and the week later in season
Tyrion Cersei made a deal on their
meeting exactly when the camera cut away
and it's tearing who told Cersei to
promise John and Danny did help in the
wars to come didn't realize that Cersei
is pregnant and he's probably working to
put at lanes throne the throne ensuring
the future of his house how else could
you explain why Sir she refused to help
John and Danny in the war against the
night king only a bit later after her
meeting with Tyrion come back at the
dragon pit and promised Danny to Aidan
even though her intention is still the
same she doesn't intend to aid them why
would she change her mind all the sudden
she did not change her mind she is still
not going to help them but what made her
say that she would who smart idea was
that Kai burns no it's the one Cersei
had a meeting with just a few moments
earlier her sibling tyrion tyrion knows
her she was not going to go north as she
said it herself
and he knew nothing could change your
mind and so he told her to lie about it
for now
Taryn told her to make a false promise
of supporting them with the troops and
that they by herself more time to
improve and build armies although not
confirmed all the clues point out to
Tyrion betraying Dany which would be the
final phase of the series not only is he
a traitor but it seems he might be the
one responsible for King's Landing
burning from the fifth episode of the
second season we know for a fact that
there's enough wildfire to burn the
entire capital
Asteria shocking was stated himself when
visiting the Pyromancer although it's
more shocking that Tyrion might be the
one actually using it in such manner
Jaime saved the city from the Mad King
and will possibly save it from Cersei as
well during the final season but he will
not be able to save it from his sibling
Tyrion who will according to this lake
decide to burn everything and everyone
down preventing the knight King from
taking it before he even arrives there
yep guys interesting details from
scripts that provided as an answers on
some of the most frequently asked
questions in the game a trans community
yes sir C's pregnant yes Tyrion loves
Dani but he also fears her and sister as
her father's daughter will he betray her
he most likely already did let me remind
you that we have a December giveaway
going in which three of you will win
Christmas Game of Thrones sweaters so
make sure to LIKE this video and leave a
nice comment to get a chance so we need
this giveaway and of course if you're
not already subscribed make sure to do
so anyway there's many more important
questions being answering in scripts and
that's what I'm going to talk about in
one of my next videos and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]
[Music]